ukrainians living in the central city of
dinipro woke up to the booms and
fireballs of three airstrikes on friday
then this scene
charred buildings cars even the trees
blackened fragments
emergency officials say one person was
killed and the air strikes hit near a
kindergarten and an apartment building
targeting civilian areas is a violation
of the geneva convention
russia has warned it will surround
dinipro
home to about one million people before
the invasion
in kharkiv ukraine's second largest city
there were reports of shelling from the
skies and the streets
on the diplomatic front the united
states with the g7 nations and the
european union are preparing to revoke
russia's most favored nation status for
trade
russia planned to ask the u.n security
council to discuss its allegations that
ukraine is developing biological weapons
earlier in the week russia accused the
ukrainian military of using phosphorus
it's illegal if used against civilians
in the suburbs of the capital kiev the
toll of several days of fighting was
coming into focus
the people just went home and a rocket
hit them so you can see what happened
here
the russians are demoralized unmotivated
and splitting into small groups
except harming civilians raping and
looting nothing is happening
even though their homes have been
reduced to rubble some are choosing to
remain
a man in the town of buca says despite
the loss and the shock they're no longer
afraid
natasha named al jazeera